ja war unsere schlagzeile von heute
teuerster heitz winter aller zeiten ist
etwas was mich tatsächlich bewegt und es
passt auch ein bisschen zu dem was ihr
am anfang gesagt wird nämlich zu
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel thomas hat
gesagt viele werden sie vermissen viele
werden sie aber auch erinnern und zwar
genau dafür für den teuersten heitz
winter aller zeiten angela merkel hat
quasi im alleingang gegen europa gegen
europäische widerstände die russische
gaspipeline nord stream 2 nach
deutschland durchgesetzt und es war
immer vollkommen klar dass wenn man
jemanden wie wladimir putin ein solches
instrument in die hand gibt mit dem air
europa erpressen kann dass er europa
irgendwann erpressen würde und
überraschungen wladimir putin macht es
im ersten winter nach der fertigstellung
von nord stream zwei damit viel gas
schnell durch nord stream 2 durch
schließen da er drosselt er die menge
bei nordstream 1 bei der anderen
pipeline und dadurch geht der gaspreis
natürlich kräftig in die höhe knallharte
machtpolitik von wladimir putin genau
das wovon angela merkel uns immer
versprochen hat nein nein keine sorge
das wird schon nicht passieren angela
merkel beschert uns mit ihrer politik
ein entweder sehr kalten winter wenn man
diese hohen gaspreise sich nicht leisten
kann oder aber eben ein sehr teuren
winter und das ist eigentlich das ist
eine bittere ein bitteres erbe eine
bittere logistik die angela merkel
dahinter lässt weil sie nicht nur für
weniger geld im portemonnaie stehen
sondern auch für die strategische
abhängigkeit von einem der schlimmsten
despoten und diktatoren auf dieser welt
von jemanden der gerade wieder
erfolgreich seine wiederwahl gefälscht
von jemandem der unweit des kanzleramts
präsidenten hat umbringen lassen angela
merkel hat sich da aus welchen gründen
auch immer nachvollziehbar ist es für
mich bis heute nicht sehr blauäugig in
diese politik hinein begeben hat sich
von diesem mann da sehen wir es blumen
schenken lassen bei ihrem letzten besuch
und die ganz freudig entgegengenommen
und die quittung dafür bezahlen wir und
die quittung kommt in form unserer
gasrechnung das wird teuer angela
merkels abschiedsgeschenk an alle
deutschen der teuerste heitz winter
aller zeiten weil sie unsere energie
abhängigkeit in die hände dieses
grauenvollen despoten gegeben hat und
jetzt
abschied sie sich und hinterlässt uns
die rechnung julian reichelt
[Musik]